hello my name is Michael man and I'm a
thoracic surgeon at the University of
California out here in San
Francisco today I'd like to talk to you
about the use of a molecular prognostic
tool to assist in the management of
early stage non-s small cell lung
cancer in the here and now the question
that I'm going to address is whether or
not we're ready to be introducing
molecular prognostic data into the
routine management of early stage
patients as a support for the decision
making that is currently based entirely
on tnm traditional staging I would very
much like to thank the organizers of uh
bio conference for affording us this
opportunity to talk today about what we
hope is going to increasingly become the
first first step towards true molecular
personalization of a disease that has
been in desperate need of improved
management uh for a very long
time uh in the spirit of full disclosure
I would like to mention uh that I uh am
and have worked as a consultant for Life
Technologies and more recently a
thermofisher scientific who own and who
run uh the molecular tool that's going
to be a large focus of today's talk
I'd like to set the stage uh for what
we're going to try to accomplish over
the next 45 or so minutes uh it should
not be hard for me to convince uh all of
the listeners of this talk that there's
a desperate need for better more refined
prognostic information in the management
of early stage lung
cancer what might be a little bit more
controversial is that I'd like to
convince you as as well that there's an
IM an immediate clinical utility for the
use of this improved prognostic
information that can allow better
differentiation of high and low-risk
patients within stages one and two of
this disease at the present time based
entirely on the data uh that we have at
our hands right now and the clinical
situation of our
patients finally uh I hope again it's uh
a little easier to convince you that
there actually is a tool that is
extremely well validated and therefore
ready uh for implementation in this type
of refined uh molecular prognostic
approach to lung
cancer now if we think about traditional
staging uh which is really the
fundamental basis of all of the
decision- making uh for non-s small cell
lung cancer uh we we were very excited
and and enthusiastic uh about the
introduction of the seventh edition of
the lung cancer uh non- small cell lung
cancer staging system in 2009 it was
based on a large amount of uh clinical
data and a large amount of uh really
great work uh poured in from around the
world but the Achilles heel of that
staging system is that it remains based
entirely on anatomic and histologic
criteria clinical criteria that have
been available to us as clinicians for
decades of not centuries and
unfortunately there seems to be a
ceiling to the degree to which we can
take the
accuracy uh of and and really the
refinement of prognosis that we're able
to achieve based entirely on those
traditional
criteria the most striking example is
probably the failure of this new staging
system to afford US an early stage
categorization that really did much
better than our older staging systems at
identifying those patients who are most
likely to be cured cured with surgery
alone and and those patients uh who are
going to recur with metastatic disease
and who are therefore much more likely
to benefit from further agant systemic
therapy now the widespread uh screening
for non-s small cell lung cancer is
still a bit of a controversial topic
we're hoping uh as uh clinicians in this
field that we're moving toward earlier
and earlier diagnos is of this disease
suffice it to say that even with greater
use of of chest CT scanning we're going
to continue to find more and more early
stage lung cancers so being able to make
better clinical decisions for those
earliest stage patients is really going
to become only more important in the
future uh as they begin to dominate more
the clinical picture of lung cancer
which in the past was much more heavily
weighted towards uh diagnosis at later
stages so why do early stage patients
die if they've had a good operation
uh why is it that we're not curing 100%
of these patients or at least 90% of
these patients which is much more of the
standard the bar that's reached by other
uh very common solid tumors such as
breast cancer and colon cancer so of
course lung cancer patients do tend to
be an older population they still a
higher concentration of smokers among
that population and so of course they
have many other diseases that can
contribute to their mortality but by and
large the vast majority of patients
after an operation for early stage lung
cancer who die within 5 years die from a
recurrence of their non-s small cell
lung cancer and that means that there
was metastic disease that if they had a
good operation must have been present at
the time of resection of their primary
tumor but since they were early stag by
the traditional staging system we just
didn't know that that metastatic disease
was there now we've always already
mentioned that the lung cancer Community
has been frustrated by a failure to
really dramatically improve the outcomes
even in early stage disease and and
that's going back now 30 to 40 years in
fact most of the more recent progress
has been not in early stage disease but
in later stages where finally we're
getting a taste of uh personalization of
care with regard to targeted agents but
those agents so far are really only
documented to help in late stage disease
so what about our early stage patients
that are still despite surgery facing 30
to 60%
mortality well if we just said that most
of these patients are dying with
metastatic disease and that metastatic
disease almost certainly was present at
the time that they underwent their
initial operation can we really think of
this perhaps as an understaging of their
disease in other words are these really
early stage patients if they're
harboring metastatic disease at the time
of their reection
and if they are understaged if they're
really later stage patients perhaps
already in stage four disease with micro
metastasis are we undertreating them by
leaving them with surgery alone and
hoping for the best on subsequent uh
radiologic uh surveillance and and other
close
followup there's another reason why
better prognostic refinement of
high-risk patients in early stage nons
small cell lung cancer is such an imp
imperative and that's because there is
clear evidence that we might be able to
intervene and to do something meaningful
to reduce the risk of these patients
eventually succumbing to their
disease now this is a little bit of a
switch for uh non-s small cell lung
cancer in which we think of chemotherapy
as an agent that can slightly prolong
survival but not really achieve cure and
that's true for Mo most late St age
patients but the data from now multiple
large scale perspective studies is that
we not only add a few months of survival
to patients who undergo adant
chemotherapy for early stage disease but
we're actually curing a decent swath of
those patients and giving them long-term
survival that they otherwise would not
have enjoyed without the chemotherapy we
know that from studies uh that were
conducted on on a large scale with uh
Platinum dublet uh
chemotherapies and we know that the
greatest benefit has tended to be seen
in those patients with the greatest risk
of recurrence and that's really uh very
intuitive and uh somewhat logical that
those patients who are most likely to
recur have tended in each of the studies
that has had a positive result those
higher risk patients I.E patients at
higher stages of disease have tended to
benefit more from from adant
chemotherapy than the lower stage
patients so we do have something to do
for patients who are at high risk for
recurrence and that intervention can
actually save
lives
so how do we convert that into action at
this at this date and time in the
history of the management of nons small
cell lung cancer well for stage two
disease you might be thinking there is
already a recommendation for adant
chemotherapy on the books and that's
true for most stage 2
patients a subpopulation of patients in
stage 2 a and all patients in stage 2 B
but as you look across the country and
across the world everyone who treats
this disease knows that there's really
suboptimal compliance with those
recommendations not every stage two
patient undergoes the adant chemotherapy
that's recommended and if we think about
why that's true a large part of that
probably comes from the statistics
themselves the studies that have been
been done in Tel that have demonstrated
a benefit for stage two patients have
looked at all comers high risk and low
risk and when you look at all comers the
absolute degree of benefit for adant
chemotherapy is relatively small
absolute benefits in the range of five
to 10 maybe
12% and when faced with the prospect of
a very difficult Platinum based
chemotherapy right when patients
recovering from a difficult
thoracotomy a lot of patients turn to
their doctors and say I don't think so
the the the likelihood of my benefit is
too small and the shity of uh having to
suffer through the chemotherapy is too
real now if those patients had a way to
understand that they were at unusually
high risk for recurrence that calculus
may be very very different and we might
see a much higher compliance among
patients who knew that their more
accurate assessment of risk put them in
a much higher risk group for recurrence
the situation in stage one is even more
desperate because for most stage one
patients there is no recommendation for
adant chemotherapy and yet at least 30%
of those patients are going to recur
stage two it's closer to 45 or even 50%
of those
patients and so even uh organizations
such as the
nccn have looked at this scenario and
they've said it's really unacceptable
for us to rely on tnm staging alone
because too many of these stage one
patients are dying from recurrence when
we know that adant chemotherapy at least
has a chance to eliminate
micrometastatic
disease however previous clinical
studies have just not given us a firm
enough ground to be able to recommend
that all stage one patients undergo Aden
chemotherapy or that even All Stage 1B
patients undergo chemotherapy and so the
nccn looking at this very difficult
clinical situation has made the
recommendation that we look at the
highest risk stage 1 patients which by
definition is stage 1B and that we look
among those patients for signs that
there are even higher risk in an
individual case and if we see signs of
even higher risk than nccn says go ahead
treat those patients with chemotherapy
even in the absence of prospective
clinical studies because those patients
are at such a high risk of occurrence
and there is at least a chance that ad
chemotherapy could modify that
risk now that recommendation of course
is a level 2B recommendation it's a
consensus recommendation but it's not
supported by prospective clinical uh
studies it's important to remember
though that the default level of support
for nccn lung cancer uh guidelines is 2A
which is again Lower Level evidence with
no randomized
data since there are data that suggest a
benefit to patients who are most likely
to Har
metastasis clinicians really have only
one choice and that's to synthesize the
best possible available information for
every patient to assess their risk
translate that risk into a potential
likelihood of benefit and then make a
very difficult decision in each
individual case should we stay where we
are after surgery or should we move
forward and try to reduce the very high
risk of recurrence it's always been the
case in medicine that more accurate
information leads to better decisions
and more informed decisions lead to
better
outcomes so if it's true that better
prognostic differentiation of risk in
non-s small cell lung cancer would at
least better support current nccn
recommendations and potentially lead to
better outcomes is there a molecular
tool Beyond traditional tnm uh
histologic and anatomic staging that
clinicians can turn to for this type of
more
precise risk stratification in this
disease well this is hardly a new topic
and it's been over a decade since the
first researchers tried to attack this
important
problem as many as 15 Studies have been
published with some degree of success in
differentiating Risk based on a
molecular profile of the tumor tissue
itself so researchers have looked at an
expression profile what genes are on
what genes are being turned off in the
lung cancer tissue itself
and they for sure have been able as has
been done in other cancers to
differentiate a patient's
prognosis but as you can see from this
graph the vast majority of these Studies
have been run with Frozen tissue
pristine tissue brought back to the
laboratory from the operating room and a
lot of these Studies have therefore been
able to depend on micro analysis that
really leverages the very high quality
RNA that can be derived from these
Frozen samples but let's ask ourselves
an important practical question are
surgeons around the country much less
around the world really going to be snap
freezing their patients tissue and
liquid nitrogen in the operating room to
facilitate this kind of analysis the
answer of course is no not at least in
the near
future so Frozen tissue may present a
barrier to widespread implementation of
a molecular approach to this problem now
authors such as Simon and subber Manan
looked at this uh conundrum several
years ago and they stipulated that there
were certain requirements that needed to
be met if clinicians on a wides scale
widescale basis were going to use a new
molecular tool to guide decision-making
for their early stage patients they
postulated that a tool would have to be
practical and that's where Frozen tissue
uh May stumble it has to be reproducible
and that may be an area where micro Ray
analysis uh is not the best tool but
they said particularly it had to have
largescale independent validation and
the studies that have been published to
date just have uh at least up until uh
uh 2010 or 11 had not really come
through with that uh promise of large
scale blinded independent validation in
fact the one time when blinded
validation was attempted there was
really a failure of the assay under
study to differentiate risk in stage one
of disease which is perhaps where the
greatest need lies so my colleagues and
I at the University of California uh
took on this challenge uh about five or
six years ago and we decided that we
needed to begin our study with the goal
of having a practical tool that was
based on paraffin tissue that would be
available for every patient who
underwent reection for non-s small cell
lung cancer so we started with paraffin
tissues we had been among the authors
who had previously looked uh at
expression profiles from Frozen tissue
so we had an idea about which genes were
a good Target set for developing a
practical profile and eventually we were
able to boil down our analysis to 14 uh
genes 11 of which were cancer related
three of which were uh present for uh
housekeeping purposes and we forced
ourselves to develop a quanita PCR
approach that would work well and
completely reproducibly with RNA of low
quality that could be derived from
paraffin embedded uh formal and fixed
tissue specimens we went through a very
rigorous statistical process trying to
make our new assay as as reflective at
least reflective as possible of the
idiosyncrasies of our training cohort of
over 350 patients from
UCSF but what we said was most important
about this whole process was that
whatever assay we finally came up with
it had to be independently validated in
a blinded Fashion on a large scale with
a completely independent cohort of
patients and we turned to two sources uh
for that validation uh in our backyard
here in uh Northern California we
Enlisted the uh collaboration of the
Kaiser uh research division which is a
phenomenal uh group of clinical
researchers uh who are known for their
tenacity in independent
validations and who were able to bring
to bear a large cohort of patients from
their network of Community Hospitals so
we felt it was a very good uh reflective
uh population but we felt that that was
not enough and so we turned in the other
direction so to speak across the Pacific
Ocean to our colleagues in China with
whom we've been working uh where lung
cancer is rapidly becoming an an an
amazing
epidemic and we asked them to do another
independent validation with an even
larger sample of patients uh this time
in stages one through three to
complement the stage one only analysis
that was being done in Northern
California now just to go over the assay
again uh step by step we start with
parapan uh embedded blocks that could be
uh retrieved from any Pathology
Department in the world the uh RNA
extraction was developed specifically
for paraffin embedded lung tissue and
then there's a quantitative real-time
PCR the results of which are put through
a simple formula to to uh yield a risk
score and uh patients are categorized
then as high intermediate or low risk
this assay is now known as the prenal
assay again it's commercially available
for all clinicians and that's through uh
Life Technologies uh which is now part
of the thermofisher
family well this large scale validation
turned out to be the largest uh really
ever attempted on uh a molecular
analysis for non-s small cell lung
cancer patients in early stages and the
results of both of these uh large- scale
studies uh were published together uh in
the Lancet back in
2011 and uh you can see a very uh large
number of authors we actually had to
twist the lancet's arm to allow us to
include uh that many authors on the
publication but it really reflected a
huge International effort to try to
solve this problem of needing better
refined prognostic information for early
stage lung cancer that clinicians could
rely on today and not wait years and
years uh for this type of benefit to
their
patients now just to uh give you a
little bit of information about the uh
clinical trials Consortium that helped
us in China uh their leaders in uh
Cancer Care uh from uh around uh the
country in China though for this study
uh we really uh relied uh entirely on
colleagues in Beijing uh Shanghai and
Guang Joo three of the major
Metropolitan centers uh on the Eastern
Seaboard of China where Cancer Care has
for many many years been up to
International standards and where more
recently uh we finally uh are able to
bring their clinical research capability
up to uh a global international
standards as well so here are some of
the data from those large scale
validation studies and you can see from
both of these curves that the assay
succeeded extremely well in separating
out High intermediate and low-risk
patients this is based entirely on their
molecular risk score derived entirely
from gene expression data from qpcr
based on the RNA derived from paraffin
samples on the right of your screen you
can see uh the results from Northern
California stage one patients only and
I'd like to draw your attention to the
fact that the high-risk patients have a
50% mortality at five years so that's
quite striking for stage one allcom
in China you can see that in stages 1
through 3A we had a very similar
separation uh even lower overall
survival in our high-risk patients as
one would expect uh from allomer in
stage 1 through
3A now again authors like Simon and
subber Manan insisted that any sort of
molecular Pro uh profiling prognostic
system really be independent of stage in
its ability to differentiate risk if if
it was going to be a useful tool for
clinicians over and above tnm staging
and so we asked the question within each
stage in our China population are we
able to see a separation of intermediate
high and lowrisk patients and as you can
see from these curves on the left in
stage one alone and on the right in
stage two alone from our China cohort uh
that we very easily succeeded with uh
very clear statistical significance in
separating out High intermediate and
lowrisk patients uh even stage by stage
now of course it was important that we
undertook uh both univariate and uh
perhaps even more important multivariate
uh analysis uh using Cox proportional
hazards modeling and we asked the
question uh you know is the molecular
profile really a powerful indicator of
risk of of death uh at five years in
this case sure enough not only uh did
univariate and multivariate Analysis in
the Pres pres of all of these other risk
factors bear out the relevance of a high
risk score you can see that uh when
other factors were considered the
high-risk score Far and Away became the
most powerful predictor uh of a negative
outcome I'd also like to point out that
even when we controlled the analysis uh
for tumor size which is the only one of
the high-risk criteria suggested by nccn
that has any basis in
prospective randomized clinical data
that size of tumor greater than 4 cmers
really fell by the wayside and paled uh
dramatically in comparison to the
molecular risk score in in its ability
to truly differentiate high-risk
patients that are most likely to die
within five years of their reection and
therefore most likely to be those
patients who are going to benefit from
adant
chemotherapy of course a similar
analysis uh was undertaken uh using the
data from the China uh cohort of
patients and once again the high-risk
categorization turned out to be by far
and way the most powerful predictor of
prognosis and therefore uh the most
powerful source of information for
clinicians in deciding who among their
patients are at highest risk uh after uh
reection and who are most likely uh to
be in that category of patients who
require interven vention and that we
believe would benefit from Intervention
since this was a cohort of patients in
which we had stages one two and three
represented we could even control for
stage itself in asking the question does
the uh molecular uh profile add
significantly to the prognostic analysis
for each patient and you can see uh even
uh when we factor in stage there's a
very dramatic uh uh hazard ratio for
high-risk alone and uh that really
speaks to the independent information
that's available uh from this
asset now one other thing I'd like to
point out that when we think about this
new staging system that that we are uh
and should be very proud of uh as of
2009 although many tens of thousands of
patients were considered in the end only
16,000 patients made the cut and had
enough clinical data available for the
development of that staging system and
among stage one patients after the
analysis was done there were only 2,000
patients left to validate the stage one
prognostic uh criteria well that 2,000
patient validation really isn't that
disimilar from the 1500 patient uh
validation that we ran 1,000 of which uh
roughly were uh stage one patients so
we're really talking about a validation
now of this molecular prognostic that
it's really on somewhat of a similar
scale to the uh new tnm staging system
itself that speaks to clinicians ability
to rely on these data uh for really
accurate prognostic information for
their patients now we're often
asked uh how to statistically compare
this molecular prognostic tool to
traditional tnm staging and that's where
clinicians need to be a little Savvy in
recognizing that there's 's a difference
between a diagnostic tool and a
prognostic tool in terms of statistical
comparison for example we can't really
talk about specificity and sensitivity
with a prognostic tool because those
Concepts don't apply in a stochastic
assay that's really just assigning a
risk but is not assigning a definitive
diagnosis and
so at the uh suggestion of authors such
as Simon and subber Manan we realized
that we had to turn to other types of
statistical tools to really more
aggressively test the ability of this
molecular assay to improve upon uh
prognosis compared to traditional
criteria including tnm staging staging
and even including the
nccn uh supplementation of tnm staging
and this uh graph represents an Oro
analysis or area under the receiver
operating curve analysis which really is
a tool much more designed to compare
prognostic tests and without getting
into too much detail about the mechanics
of this type of uh statistical approach
suffice it to say that when we use this
tool to compare the molecular assay to
nccn criteria alone there was a dramatic
Improvement in the accuracy of
prognosis uh represented here
graphically in the dark blue shaded area
in which we really able to achieve a
much better discrimination using the
molecular profile
to assign prognosis to assign a risk
category to the patient compared to
traditional criteria including the
highrisk criteria that nccn has
recommended uh for determining candidacy
for
chemotherapy now uh in early stage
disease there's a subcategory of
patients who we believe have the
absolute best prognosis and those are
patients with uh so-called t1a tumors
tumors less than 2 cmers in greatest
diameter of course are also node
negative and therefore stage one we
congratulate those patients when we see
them postoperatively in our surgical
clinics because we believe that those
patients have the best prognosis and we
would never have considered further
adant intervention for those patients
based on uh traditional prognostic uh
systems alone so we ask the very
difficult question of our uh new
molecular assay can you take even those
earliest of stage staged patients and
still identify patients who are at very
high risk for recurrence and who might
actually benefit tremendously from
additional adant chemotherapy to lower
their risk of death and sure enough we
found that this molecular assay even
among stage uh 1A t1a patients with only
2 cimeter or smaller tumors we were able
to identify a cohort of high-risk
patients that again approached a 50%
mortality at 5 years now that's just
unaccept acceptable uh mortality to
allow patients to go on uh when we know
that chemotherapy tends to reduce the
chance of deaths death for high risk
highest risk patients and it wasn't just
a small sliver of those very very early
stage patients that fell into that
high-risk category as you can see from
the numbers at the bottom of this graph
it was fully a third of those patients
that for whom we were able to identify a
very very high risk of occurrence so
this is really uh a very important an uh
progress that could be applied to the
management of this increasingly large uh
percentage of early stage non-s small
cell lung cancer patients who are
increasingly going to come to our
attention as screening and uh the more
widespread use of CT scanning in general
brings more early uh stage patients uh
to diagnosis and for whom this challenge
of identifying those patients who
despite having an early uh
traditional clinical pathologic stage
are very likely already to Harbor
undetectable microm
metastasis now uh again uh in fullness
to full disclosure uh since those data
were published a second molecular
prognostic essay has uh been described
in the literature and you can see uh
last year uh in clinical cancer research
there's there was a report of the
validation uh of a similar type of uh
RNA based uh molecular profiling
assay however that assay was really
based uh on a test that was developed uh
using prostate cancer uh and not
specifically for lung cancer patients
and that uh validation uh tended to
suffer from a number of uh clinical
scientific uh challenges uh and problems
uh related to implementation of the use
of that essay specifically uh they uh
never succeeded in Def predefining a
cuto off for a score between high and
low risk uh therefore leaving uh
clinicians uh really uh with a a mystery
as to how to interpret uh the results of
the assay for their patients and a
clinical offering uh that has been based
uh on this assay uh really depended very
heavily on classical tnm staging to
provide uh a risk categorization so it
it hasn't been very clear from the data
that have been available whether there
is uh really a boost uh to prognostic a
uh accuracy provided by this second
molecular assay it does however speak to
both the need and the feasibility of
developing a uh gene expression based
approach to differentiation of risk in
uh early stage lung cancer and it may
also speak to the need for uh cancer uh
type specific development velopment uh
of the assay as far as I'm aware uh this
assay is not yet available uh for
widespread use uh as is again the pral
assay which is now available from Life
technology uh Clea
laboratory now uh we had a chance at
last year's bio conference uh to talk
about this assay uh since then there
have been a couple of new studies uh
either published or uh in press that
have addressed more specifically the
question of clinical utility for this uh
new approach to integrating molecular uh
prognostic information into the
management of uh of early stage lung
cancer one study uh by dormand and
colleagues uh specifically asked the
question um is it are clinicians who are
obtaining this assay for their early
stage patients actually using that
information to modify their uh clinical
decisions regarding those patients and
uh the results of that study uh
portrayed in this uh chart indicate that
a full 30% uh or slightly above 30% of
all of the patients entered into this
study actually had management decisions
that were changed as a result of
obtaining the assay about 120 uh unique
patients uh were considered in the study
uh roughly 50 clinicians uh
participated bringing those 120 patients
into the study but was what was perhaps
most striking about uh the results of
this study is that um if a patient uh
did not have a
pre-study uh decision to go for adant uh
intervention adant chemotherapy but
obtained a high risk score so in other
words these were patients who got a high
risk score and had not previously been
considered candidates for chemotherapy
75% of those patients ended up
undergoing adant chemotherapy as and an
attempt to reduce that high risk of uh
post-operative recurrence and death from
lung cancer so that suggests that
clinicians really are willing to rely on
this type of molecular analysis of their
individual patients tumors to influence
their clinical decision making and again
this is in the absence of specific
prognostic clinical data that guarantees
that there is a documentable benefit uh
to that approach but it's integrating
all of the data that we have available
the data that suggests that adant
chemotherapy does help patients at
higher risk of recurrence I.E highest
stage patients and that those patients
not only benefit with uh slightly
prolonged survival but with long-term uh
freedom from occurrence and from
Death now we undertook another uh study
uh looking at clinical utility uh of
this assay in a perspective fashion and
uh in this cohort from UCSF uh we
analyzed the results of 50 or so uh uh
patients who underwent prospective
molecular risk stratification and for
whom we had an average of about 15
months of followup of course this essay
has just been recently introduced and so
we don't have longer term follow-up yet
but we asked a specific question we
said can we look at the outcomes of our
patients so far and figure out if there
is a difference in the ability of this
molecular risk assessment to better
identify high risk patients compared to
the nccn high-risk criteria that are
being used right now uh to to support
decisions for adant
chemotherapy you can see that in our
cohort of uh 52 patients uh 40% were
high risk uh by both the molecular assay
and the nccn assay but these were not
the same 40% of patients there was a
substantial amount of discordance
between the risk assessment between
these two methods
37% uh of stage one and 60% of patients
in the critical stages 1B through 2A
those are the patients for whom the nccn
criteria are most important and the nccn
criteria were different from the
molecular risk profile in 60% of
patients now here are some of the data
from that study and perhaps the most
important take home about whether or not
this molecular assay is reliable one and
more reliable than the nccn criteria
number two is that zero uh lowrisk
patients according to the molecular
assay suffered recurrence during our
follow-up period where you can see a
substantial percentage as high as 30% of
the high-risk patients recurred even
with just a 15-month follow-up period
when you looked at nccn there were more
recurrences overall among their
high-risk patients compared to lowrisk
patients but even that difference wasn't
statistically significant in this cohort
and you can see that many of their
lowrisk patients actually suffered
recurrences even within 15 months look
at a different way you can see here the
discordance rates uh among all patients
uh and and especially in that critical
subcategory of stage 1B and 2A patients
for whom these decisions are the most
difficult for clinicians to make who
gets adant chemotherapy and who gets uh
uh radiographic surveillance alone and
you can see there were both kinds of
discordances there was nccn high- risk
molecular low risk and there was
molecular high risk and nccn low risk
and you you can see there was a lot of
discordance but in the end the patients
who were molecular low risk did not have
any recurrences even if they received a
high-risk categorization from nccn
criteria and you can see the lowrisk NCM
patients who got a high molecular risk
actually had as high as a 22 to
25% recurrence rate despite the fact
that they were lowrisk by nccn criteria
which would mean that they would not
have received any intervention to try to
lower that risk of recurrence and
eventual death since we know that almost
all patients who recur with uh lung
cancer after reection eventually succumb
to that
disease and I'd like to uh draw your
attention to the bottom of this slide uh
because what we also saw on this cohort
was that um there was generally even at
UCSF relatively poor compliance with
recommendations for adant chemotherapy
even in stages 1B and 2A and Stage
2B where uh again patients are are
facing a difficult decision about a
difficult chemotherapy in a
post-operative period when they're
trying to recover from an often uh
painful thorocotomy
and uh 70% of the failure to comply with
that recommendation uh was due to
Patient refusal in our Coco patients who
might benefit substantially from more
refined prognostic information telling
them that not only are they stage two or
even stage 1B but they're at
particularly high risk for recurrence
and subsequent death I'd also like to
point out that 83% of the recurrences in
this cohort again only 15 months of
followup but 83% of those early
recurrences occurred in patients who did
not undergo adant
chemotherapy 22% recurrence rate again
in the patients who were discordant with
a high molecular risk profile but a low
profile according to nccn
criteria so finally I'd like to sum up
uh by going over what we've had a chance
to discuss uh over the past 40 45
minutes I think it's clear that Although
our best tool uh to date conventional
staging still does a relatively poor job
of stratifying risk in early stage non-s
small cell lung cancer patients
particularly compared to other solid
tumors where a stage one uh
categorization usually means you have a
90% in some cases a 98% chance of uh
cure of long-term survival after
reection alone in a non-s small cell
lung cancer as many as 30 to 60% or more
of patients who are undergoing complete
attempt at Curative reection must
actually Harbor undetectable metastatic
disease and and many of whom forgo any
attempt at early systemic intervention
that might actually cure their disease
at a micromatic
stage I believe we've documented that uh
that there is reasonable evidence in
studies such as yalt uh jb10 and even
the Anita study that suggests that
micrometastatic nonm cell lung cancer
will benefit from adant chemotherapy and
that the greatest benefit is observed
among patients who are at the highest
level of risk of recurrence and death
after
surgery since nccn has already stepped
over the line and has already determined
that it should be recommended to
patients at very high risk to undergo
adant chemotherapy to reduce that risk
even in the absence of prospective data
for that category of patients the
challenge to clinicians is to make that
determination with the most reliable and
most accurate prognostic information
possible patients are going to face
these difficult decisions and better
data is almost certainly going to lead
to better decisions and therefore better
outcomes molecular prognosis based on
assays such as the one that I've
reviewed with you today the preven assay
uh has been scientifically validated as
a means of better identifying higher
risk patients and therefore perhaps
better implementing current nccn
recommendations again the validation
that we've discussed today was on a
scale uh roughly similar to the
validation of the tnm system for stage
one
itself now this this may uh support the
introduction of a slightly altered
Paradigm for the treatment of these
early uh stage lung cancer patients even
patients as early as stage 1A where the
perception of low risk has in the past
LED just to monitoring alone and When
recurrence has has uh been documented
then introducing chemotherapy that to be
in my perspective as a surgeon is really
paliative in nature in the sense that it
may prolong survival but is very very
unlikely to achieve cure instead now
we're looking at a group of patients who
have the initial perception of low risk
but who then undergo molecular
prognostic analysis now we have a much
more uh reliable uh different
differentiation of high and low risk
those lowrisk patients of course will
continue to go on uh for monitoring and
surveillance but those highrisk patients
now have the
opportunity and have better confidence
in that designation to undergo the
opportunity for intervention in in the
form of adant chemotherapy that might
actually achieve risk
reduction as they then follow on to
monitoring and hopefully a much lower
risk of recurrence uh and any need uh
for uh reintervention in the future now
again uh this is all Based on data that
have been available to the lung cancer
Community for years the question remains
can we Pro prospectively uh document
that this strategy really has teeth and
is going to result in better outcomes
for our early stage lung cancer patients
the answer is of course yes we can and
have actually designed that prospective
randomized clinical study
and it has been initiated so we are now
in the very early stages of actually uh
randomizing patients who are uh by tnm
staging criteria stage one but who
receive a high-risk designation from the
prenal assay we're randomizing those
high-risk stage one patients to adant
chemotherapy versus their traditional
standard of care uh of monitoring uh
with radiographics
surveillance and by this prospective uh
randomization we hope to document in uh
several years time that the high-risk uh
identification through the molecular
profiling actually allows for better
management decisions in the sense that
these patients receive an intervention
and therefore have better outcomes uh
compared to patients treated by the
conventional Paradigm of monitoring
alone again that study has been designed
it's been initiated
and we're hoping to see results from
that study in about uh uh four or five
years time now of course uh many many
very very talented uh clinicians and uh
clinician
scientists uh have been involved in the
development of this new clinical tool uh
would be highly remiss for me not to
acknowledge their contributions my uh
friend and uh close colleague David
jablons in our uh division of thoracic
surgery at University of California San
Francisco and the founder and leader of
our thoracic oncology program in our uh
Comprehensive Cancer Center at uccf UCSF
uh really helped me to lead this uh
development and validation program uh
and of course uh continues uh to work uh
vigilantly on a daily basis to try to
use this and other Technologies to
improve the outcomes of early stage lung
cancer patients uh Dr Dr Johannes Katz
uh who uh together with gabt Woodard uh
are completing uh their respective
trainings at UCSF contributed uh
substantially uh Johannes really being a
lynchpin in the development uh and
validation studies uh Dr Woodard more
recently uh contributing uh to our
prospective studies uh ongoing with the
UCSF lung cancer patients I mentioned
the Kaiser Northern California division
of search uh I particularly like to
mention stevenh veden uh who helped to
lead that program and who was
particularly instrumental in the
planning and the execution of our large
scale validation studies and of course
all of our wonderful colleagues uh in
China uh who participated in the
clinical trials Consortium and made the
truly very very large scale validation
of the study possible uh I might also
point out uh at this point that by
comparing a uh predominantly Caucasian
Northern Californian population to an
entirely Chinese population we really uh
were able to achieve a large degree of
confidence that our assay was not in any
way uh idiosyncratic to a single
population but really spoke to the
biology of non-s small cell lung cancer
as it manifests across the globe uh it
was not the success of the assay was not
at all dependent on the unique genetic
background of the population under study
but even with patients with very diverse
genetic background such as a northern
California population versus an entirely
Chinese population the assay was almost
identically effective in differentiating
high and lowrisk patients so uh the
China contribution to all clinicians
ability to rely on this assay was really
uh very tremendous and very much
appreciated and of course uh numerous
individuals at pinpoint genomics and
more recently at Life
Technologies uh have also been
instrumental not only in making this
essay clear
certified uh and available but really
relevant to clinicians all over the
country and uh really very soon all over
the world so uh with that uh thanks uh
to all the folks that helped to make
this clinical science possible I'd uh
particularly like to thank everybody who
joined today uh and also all of those uh
people who who will uh enjoy this talk
uh once it's posted on the web uh you
are really uh the leaders for
implementation of uh new strategies and
um more scientifically
driven uh paradigms for getting better
outcomes for our nonell lung cancer
patients nonell lung cancer is reaching
epidemic proportions and even though we
congratulate ourselves in the United
States for reducing smoking rates and
finally seeing gradual reduction in lung
cancer incidences uh globally it's a
very different story uh China is a
particular tragedy but even in other
parts of the world tobacco use is not on
the Wayne and as a result we're going to
see an even greater epidemic and wave of
uh non-sm cell lung cancer in coming
years we need uh much more refined tools
to help combat that uh immense uh Public
Health
crisis and uh to get better outcomes for
all patients of course late stage and uh
and early stage alike again I'd like to
thank everybody uh for making uh this
talk possible today and for
participating and with that uh I'll wish
you a very good
day